representantes del gobierno de nicolás
maduro y de la plataforma unitaria de
oposición de venezuela dieron a conocer
mediante un comunicado conjunto que
luego de la firma del memorándum de
entendimiento el viernes pasado
sostuvieron reuniones constructivas los
días 14 y 15 de agosto aquí en la ciudad
de mexico
destacaron que acordaron establecer
mecanismos de consulta a los actores
políticos y sociales que sean lo más
incluyentes posible este de hecho es uno
de los puntos de la agenda contenidos en
el citado memorándum presentado por el
facilitador del reino de noruega
tacna y lander cabe señalar que ambas
partes han sido en extremo cautelosos
con la reserva del proceso y se han
propuesto ser prudentes y escuetos al
emitir sus comentarios al respecto jorge
rodríguez líder de la asamblea de
venezuela y representante de maduro
señaló vía twitter que ahora regresan a
la patria de bolívar y de chávez se
reunirán de nueva cuenta del 3 al 6 de
septiembre aquí mismo en la ciudad de
mexico
eeuu la unión europea y canadá señalaron
este fin de semana que están dispuestos
y el levantamiento de sanciones a
venezuela como lo exige el régimen de
maduro si éste permite avances
significativos en las negociaciones